[Music]  the Grammy nominations are in and here's  what you need to know  Beyonce scored the most nominations nine  for lemonade and she's on track to make  Grammy history  if she wins eight of her nine  nominations she will hold the title for  most Grammys won by a female artist BAE  will go head-to-head with Adele in three  major categories album of the year a  record of the year and song of the year  both Kanye West and Rihanna got eight  noms while Justin Bieber has three  including album of the year for purpose  Demi Lovato earned her first ever  nomination Best Pop Vocal album for  confident that excited meanwhile David  Bowie's legacy lives on he garnered five  nominations for his final album  Blackstar  which was released two days prior to his  death On January 10 and Rory and Joey  feek earned one nomination following  Joey's passing in March after a long  battle with cancer  precious Lord lead me home  [Music]  you